hi Bill my name's Mike and I get told a
lot that I asked too many questions so
my question to you is what do you think
would be different if we as a culture
were more encouraging of asking
questions and being inquisitive and you
know trying to learn trying to
understand things especially with kids
this is a great question can you ask too
many questions
I mean hypothetically you cannot ask too
many questions you cannot investigate
too thoroughly could you possibly
however what your friends may be
responding to something a little
different if somebody is trying to
execute a task let's say so on a button
and you ask this person why are you
sewing on a button while you're using
thread to sew on a button why are you
using a needle and thread to sew on a
button the person would think that
you're not paying attention this is
possible that you're not thinking for
yourself that you're not using your own
common sense I'm not saying that's
what's happening but you reported at the
top of your little segment here that
people say you ask too many questions I
don't know in other words it could be a
social interaction thing if you were
sewing on a button in general you're
doing it because the button fell off or
the button has never been put on that
piece of clothing in the first place and
you're using a needle and thread because
that as our current button attaching
technology there are other technology
little plastic strings but they're not
nearly as aesthetically pleasing as
thread so I mentioned this only by way
of example along this line if you were
I'm in New York right now and it's the
holiday season and on very famous
department store it says believe in the
holiday season wouldn't it be better or
how would it be different if it said
question whoa
that's a good question man of questions
but be aware of your surroundings be
aware of social interactions don't annoy
people
carry on